the US dollar has a pretty privileged
position among world currencies which is
good for the United States because it's
a trading currency it's a reserve
currency in many parts of the world so
it's not just within the United States
that the dollar is used it's used by
countries all over the world for
transactions between many other
countries forty to forty five percent of
international payments happen in dollars
two-thirds of global reserves are in
dollars two-thirds of physical dollar
bills are outside of the United States
this global reliance on the dollar keeps
interest rates low which is good for our
economy it's really easy to sell US
bonds because a lot of the world is
already operating in dollars and trading
with other countries meaning imports and
exports trading with other countries is
one step easier for the United States
because our currency happens to be one
that's already being used by many other
countries but the consequences would be
bigger than just these numbers if the
United States dollar were no longer such
a prominent currency we have clout
economically around the world and
diplomatically around the world because
of the prevalence of our currency being
used by different countries the world
wants dollars which makes American
exports worth more this is where we get
to the current administration
unfortunately under Donald Trump under
this increased geopolitical economic
diplomatic instability that a surfaced
under Trump we're seeing the world start
to move away from u.s. dollars more and
more and it is really important to
understand this we might feel as though
obviously the dollar is the currency of
the world
it's nothing fixed or immutable about
that it might seem like dollars are at
the top of the food chain but the reason
for that is a lot of what I've told you
and the fact that the US has been seen
as a sort of stable geopolitical player
that can be trusted to stick to our
agreements to be present in our
alliances that's increasingly in
question and there are two sort of
unrelated ways in which Donald Trump is
causing the self-inflicted demise of the
dollar number one is that the status of
the u.s. around the world as
untrustworthy hurts our credibility this
includes Trump backing out of agreements
for no good reason
this includes you know the Iran deal the
Paris climate deal that's the sort of
geopolitical attack on the dollar that
we're seeing
then there's the economic one trumps
tariffs for example buy by virtue of how
they impact our allies push other
countries to say maybe maybe we don't
want to be dealing in the dollar the
dollar starts to become a risk for other
countries to hold rather than a stable
mechanism and then we get to one of the
most interesting aspects of this Donald
Trump has been talking about how the
trade deficit is really a bad thing
meaning when we have a trade deficit we
are importing more than we are exporting
or we are buying more than we're selling
we're consuming more than we are
producing what that means is that we
have to borrow at the country level to
pay for a lot of that stuff that we're
consuming that means more dollars are
going out than dollars coming in that's
why there are all these dollars floating
around the world that other countries
use for transactions and make it easier
for them to use the dollar as their
reserve currency if Trump succeeds in
getting rid of our trade deficit the
number of extra dollars around the world
goes way down which hurts our clout as a
reserve currency basic economics and
very quickly this starts to get into way
more sort of advanced economics then
certainly Trump can understand but the
point is that the same trade deficit
that Donald Trump claims to want to get
rid of to help the United States would
actually be even more damaging to the US
dollar if he did it he claims to be a
nationalist that's his word if
that's the case why is he advocating a
policy that would be bad for the US
dollar the national currency which I
would imagine nationalists would want to
support send me your thoughts on that
we're going to talk more about it on
upcoming programs